the idea of Communism is evil in and of  itself and it leads to evil outcomes  because it is an evil idea the idea that  you must force people to be equal is  evil whether you're looking at it  through the lens of class or race or sex  or gender or whatever other [ __ ]  people have come up with the idea that  you must put your hand on the lever and  take from people who have drive an  ambition and creativity and whatever  else you must take from them as much as  possible and give it to people who have  none of those things and who are not  contributing to society that's an evil  idea and we should just be very clear  about and the reason it's evil is not  that it's not a good thing to  redistribute wealth and income from one  group of people to another it's the  amount of tyranny that it takes to  achieve is inevitably going to lead to  millions of people being killed as it  has done every time it's been tried okay  uh I don't recognize that  characterization but uh fair dude um